so today we want to talk about the three
reasons why you should skip your
breakfast now a lot of you watching are
already skipping your breakfast so this
video is not for you
it's for those people that are new to my
channel and are hearing the opposing
viewpoint where you need to consume a
good breakfast and I personally used to
promote that before I realize that's not
the best thing to do but I had a serious
blood sugar issue I had hypoglycemia and
of course when you eat you feel better
so then I have this realization that
works so well for me that I'm gonna
recommend it and even in my earlier
books however here's the here's the
problem when you eat you stimulate
insulin okay and insulin creates a lot
of issues not just with slowing your
metabolism over time but it sets you up
for a another blood sugar problem so
intermittent fasting is very very very
important so the first point I want to
bring up is if you eat breakfast you're
going to stimulate your metabolism okay
you're gonna increase your enzymes and
all these different activities well what
you're really doing is like I said
before you're increasing insulin insulin
actually slows your metabolism it stops
your fat burning okay so number one
eating a breakfast actually will not
increase your metabolism it slows your
metabolism number two you're breaking
the fast all night long you're in a
fasting state you're burning fat your
brain is being fed ketones hopefully and
then you eat you break the fast so you
raise insulin now you nullify the
benefits of fasting you're gonna
actually kind of nullify the top of goog
is the recycling action of your cells so
your cells are cleaning all that junk
out of them and I'm talking about you
know especially out of your brain so all
the waste that's accumulating all the
added damaged proteins are being cleaned
up so this is part of the repair cycle
so you actually stop preparing the body
when you eat because the body is
focusing on digestion especially in your
digestive tract if you're constantly
eating you never have a chance to repair
that so we we nullify a toff og
we stopped the new brain cells from
forming because one of the benefits of
fasting is that you you have
neurogenesis you've been actually make
new brain cells and you stopped the
anti-inflammatory effect so if you have
inflammation or arthritis you just won't
ever go away if you keep eating and then
used to stop repairing okay so number
three if you're consuming the typical
breakfast foods where there cereals or
orange juice toast pancakes waffles
fruit sweet and yogurt that type of
thing Wow what's gonna happen is that
you're gonna create up a nice big spike
in insulin it's gonna come down about 90
minutes later and you're gonna be really
really hungry right before a lunchtime
okay not to mention craving sweets and
then because the blood sugars now are
going up and down you're gonna notice
also at night you're gonna crave the
wrong foods so those people that crave
at night usually are eating too many
carbs in the morning or too many carbs
the day before so just make a mental
note of that if you're not hungry don't
eat ride the wave for as long as you can
and then maybe have your meal right at
noon that can be your first meal you're
gonna feel much better and then just add
one more meal for dinner and you're
gonna be really impressed not just on
how much weight you lose but you're
gonna have so many benefits of just
doing that fasting from the last meal
all the way until lunch all right I'll
see you later
so if you're enjoying this content go
ahead and share it with someone that
could really benefit from it